one of the biggest hits in horror
certainly it which came out about a
little over a year ago year and a half
go and you're in the sequel yeah I'm in
it - you're in it - yeah and there's
this amazing picture of you with Bill
skarsgård yeah and it's you guys just
talking I think on the set can we see
that and I just man you're really
cracking him up you're really one of the
funniest nicest guys in the world me and
he's when he's playing that character it
is terrifying like he'll be talking you
about like we're probably talking about
music or movies or whatever and then the
minute they say action he is so
terrifying and he can do like I go how
did they do that thing in the first
movie where your eye kind of goes up one
penny wise I know if you guys saw the
movie when he senses something he kind
of goes like ah you know whatever and
his eye goes like that and I go how is
that a digital thing and he went oh you
mean this and then he did it and then he
murdered you murdered me and Lauren went
you know when Pennywise
so this is just your first horror movie
yeah that's my first horror movie and
I'm terrible at acting scared apparently
everyday is that a problem yeah cuz when
I'm scared I think I smile what are you
I get nervous yeah I got a smile but
I'll be coming at you with a knife no
that's like we would do we would do
takes and the director any machete would
come as like bill you need to be scared
and I was terrified he goes nah man
you're smiling the whole time man what's
wrong with you and and it's true yeah
like I just like it I'm like oh gosh we
gotta get out of here Pennywise is here
[Laughter]
it's the same face you make like the ice
cream is free the ice cream is free and
it's like is that terrifying it's like
yeah North Korea has nuclear weapons I'm
like oh no maybe we should get out of
here
it's weird man you want a cigarette no
like let's get out of here I'm terrified
you are single-handedly ruining it - I
am they're like pies we need to get out
of here in a lane oh no it's it - we'll
be fine
don't say it's not coffee
the working title was its yeah I wish it
really would really do that - its it is
that's so dumb
that's the purpose of - yeah when's that
come out no no September Halloween or
something she gets nervous all right guy
was your you're a terrible at plugging a
movie